I wanted to watch this with you I'm
really looking forward there's a new
um it's a live event
that's coming up that I'm really looking
forward to yeah and you might be
thinking is it the you know the live
stream of Coachella weekend two
no not really okay it's something
similar
um here like I would pop on the website
let's watch the trailer oh
uh this is called The Art of Living and
this is a Matthew Mcconaughey live
stream it's a live event it's not a
stream it's an event okay it's an
experience can you search is there
because I the reason I found this was
there was like a promoted video on
Twitter of him describing it in his like
language yeah
greetings earthlings
is he on
R said no no this is Airstream behind oh
yeah salutations
this page has your next best steps on it
we are doing The Art of Living
experience to help you write your new
story live into who you want and need to
be
and I'm damn excited to take this
journey with you three quick things I'm
going to ask you to do first add the
date I don't remember write it on a
sticky note put it put it in your phone
uh add it on your laptop because I'm
only gonna do this one time folks
[__] engrave it into your skin yeah
when you buy an iPod and engrave the
date on the back of it with the engraved
feature yeah
branded on your own ass yeah
you know carve it into your skin with uh
with a a clothespin yeah I had the team
put a button on this page that you can
click and easily add it to your account
I had my team of [__] nerds because
it's more fun to take a road trip
together make sure you join the private
Facebook group that we created for this
event uh we're gonna Matthew
[Laughter]
who are you targeting
I know exactly who he's targeting
you know exactly who it is our moms
just
just buy a steak in an Indian scamming
company instead I mean that's what
you're trying to do yeah
mom what the [__] are you
it's what's that I'm in Matthew's face
private Facebook group they're targeting
Ryan's mom dude yeah yeah yeah your mom
yeah
Midwest sitting out there [__] my mom
sent me green lights and now it's
sitting on the table you should ask her
if she knows about this
[Laughter]
mom what what does your calendar say on
April 24th oh that's the Matthew
Mcconaughey live event that weekend I'm
I'm busy what's what's going on in the
Facebook group Matthew and do some fun
stuff they're like bonus trainings and
meeting some new people you know he
sounds like Biden
yeah he does yeah
people there's like when he's older he's
going to sound like Biden well are we
sure what like do we know what this is
yeah not yet yeah the button on this
page you can click to join right now
lastly
I'm betting that you know a few people
in your life that I like to join us on
this road trip The Art of Living
experience
so how about this what if you invited
five friends or five family members to
come along for the ride with us family
members didn't even put a message in a
link on this page that you can copy and
paste and send out to whoever you want
to invite so we can take this ride
together on the highway so you can take
this ride together
on a highway
to corn to the corn fields corn pot
cornfield
what is this [__] Matthew
what is the what it what road trip are
we going on I'm packing all these
[__] moms in my Airstream and we're
gonna hold the road
and run all their credit cards through a
square reader and
I'ma never make another movie again
damn it dude
it's it's Mom's making their lemon Loaf
and they're all gonna pile them all in
this Airstream and I'm gonna [__] them
all at first it's cute his purse is cute
but then like don't you start to feel
like Matthew McConaughey is like you
know he's just like an eagle in the sky
like hunting down your mom yeah
just
salutation salamander
cart
no see your mom being carried away into
the into the distance no I know I know
people will disagree they said maybe
ricardia wants to hook my mom he could
have her and me you know
that's what happens when you're sexy two
more there's also more info if you need
it below this video okay let's get the
more info
played to the end we're almost there
okay all right
so check it out if you want that is a
wrap until I see you there in the
meantime in all times
just keep living
how many steps you think he took
backwards after that take
he looked all the way back and cut yeah
okay okay so important steps to prepare
for the event you got to add it to your
calendar right right right right okay
what else
you gotta join the private Community I
have a community right
invite your family and friends family
members family members
go down
copy this text below and share it we
must do this dude this is a call Luke
tweet this from teams
PMG account actually right now tweet it
right now
tweet it right now don't explain
click here to download back you know
it's going to be one of those like see
more tweets yeah yeah just too long yes
yeah post it right now dude click here
to see to download badge
yes and we need the badge
and bro what
what happened you click it's a PNG you
clicked the click here download badge
and just brought you to a piano a
separate for what which is a PNG dude
they are completely targeting like 58
year old people
oh what do you mean oh no no no that's
hilarious but no
I like your idea oh wait there's a VIP
Fastpass members oh it's a fast pass
what a scammy ass URL dude
fastpassvip.com does that get you into
the stream first that's a browser
hijacker if I've seen one click that
dude
fast ass
watch this quick message from
McConaughey to Mac dude this is so s
spammy yeah
this looks like every single one of
those websites that you click on that
like you know e-commerce like gurus will
sell their course they all look like
this click here huge green buttons yeah
click here to upgrades upgrade your
experiences like what am I even buying
what is this here's what you get let's
see what we get let's see what we got
with the VIP experience now scroll down
yeah I feel like we shouldn't tweet this
because people are gonna it's gonna send
it to people yeah
the VIP fat it's just 40 it's just forty
seven dollars hold on what's what's the
date of it the 24th [__] man it'd be so
funny if we did like a you know Joe
Rogan like watches the fights live
if we did if we watched if we did it
thing where we watched this stream live
oh on what day for team G Studios or
something what's the 24th of Monday
yeah I just know five minutes and I'm
gonna be so bored
it's gonna feel like school yeah it
probably is just like sure to me it's
gonna feel like a it's probably gonna
feel like a Morning Show yeah
like where he walks over to who was that
Tony Robbins yeah
bro the background as well like scroll
up the uh
oh wait they give you a custom
background for zoom because you can also
get Zoom access
oh my God bro Zoom access to what uh
probably whatever this experience is
they'll probably put you on the big
screen with you yeah you could talk to
Maddie he may speak to you I mean
[__] buy that immediately
how much is it 47 bucks dude
damn
that's so spammy look at all this stuff
for 17 we get lifetime access
oh what's the company that does this
I believe it's mind meant mindment
mindment dot in aggregator of expert
there we go
the marketplace for knowledge givers
what a not smart way to say that dude
knowledge Giver
I'm an information provider all right
all right all right welcome to the
Stream
what is a stream it's a it's not a creek
but it's like it's not a river
life is a river
but a stream
well that's just us
I don't know what he'd say that was
pretty good I don't know what he'd say
this is crazy man
well yeah we're gonna look up
McConaughey nudes in the bum so